hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and those of
you who've been following my stuff over
the years know that I'm very interested
in quantum mechanics the foundations of
quantum mechanics what it all means and
in particular I'm a proponent and
advocate for the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics I
think it's probably the right one but
you know there are smart people who
disagree so therefore on today's episode
we're gonna feature a smart person who
disagrees David Albert is a philosopher
of physics at Columbia University he got
his PhD in physics from rockefeller and
he is one of the leading figures in the
world on the foundations of quantum
mechanics he is not a fan of many worlds
of what we call Eveready in quantum
theory and so we're gonna dig into what
makes him such a skeptic sadly we didn't
get quite enough time to talk about what
issues what approaches to quantum
mechanics he is in favor of but that's
okay maybe we'll come back for a new
podcast some other time we're gonna
explain what quantum mechanics is with a
measurement problem is what the many
worlds theory says and the particular
puzzles he sees that he does not feel
optimistic that many worlds is going to
be able to answer well this is a very
useful podcast to listen to if you're
kind of interested in this area but
aren't an expert both because we sort of
clear up what are the silly objections
to many worlds and focus on what we
agree are the important puzzles the
important challenges to many worlds
David knows perfectly well that many
worlds the plausible theory but he just
thinks that the obstacles to getting it
right are not going to be solved whereas
I think that they are going to be the
other reason is because this is a master
class in careful philosophical reasoning
David is extremely good about not using
any jargon either physics jargon or
philosophy jargon but also very good at
very carefully precisely rigorously
setting out what the issues are looking
at the different alternatives so I
personally do not reach the same
conclusions from that analysis that
David does but I always have time to
listen to him in fact I actually got a
couple of new ideas just while we had
this conversation so I hope that you get
some new ideas too
let me just mention the
occasional podcast notes you are very
welcome and encouraged to support
mindscape by donating on patreon or
PayPal you can check out the website
preposterous universe comm slash podcast
to figure out how to do that and of
course we'd love to get good reviews on
iTunes or elsewhere and with that let's
go
[Music]
David Albert welcome to the mindscape
podcast glad to be here and will warns
listeners ahead of time that we're here
in your apartment in Manhattan and we
have a guest speaker in the form of
Leroy a little dog so anyone hears barks
don't fear for our safety that's all
part of the experience so you're a I'll
start with an amusing anecdote which I
read in Adam Becker's book about you and
I'm bought by the way I'm writing my own
book on quantum mechanics as my
listeners know and I'm gonna rewrite
that anecdote it's gonna be no good and
it's about your experience as a graduate
student at Rockefeller and you made the
mistake of reading a book by David Hume
I understand correctly alright got you
interested in foundations and what
happened but well there was a that
wasn't received warmly at Rockefeller
this is in a physics department this
wasn't in the physics department at
Rockefeller there were within fairly
short order proceedings instituted to to
expel me from PhD program this was back
in the late 1970s early 1980s so this
was in the dark old days but but
worrying about issues like that was
profoundly unpopular I was I said you
know I got to stay in the program on the
condition that I would do a I would work
on a thesis topic assigned to me by the
department instead of one that I chose
and the one that was assigned was
clearly one that was thought to be good
for my character it was an extremely
calculation heavy it was something on
about Burrell risa mation in fight of
the four field theories which people
were playing around with in those days
it was extremely computation heavy
the thesis topic I sort of I had I had
been in contact at that time we're ready
with the akhir Hirono of who I had
written to while I was a graduate
student telling him some questions that
I was struggling with didn't know what
to do with asked for his advice he was
wonderful and I did go to him when I was
given a pretty stark choice at a meeting
in the dean's office that either I was
going to do a thesis topic assigned to
me by the department or I was going to
leave the ph.d program and I said okay
you know could I have a couple of days
to think this over and went to got in
touch with a [ __ ] enough who was very
nice and and had been very close at the
time for example to Leonard Susskind and
said you know I could talk to Lenny
maybe we could we could transfer you to
to I guess he was at Stanford at that
time we could you know you could
transfer to Stanford or something like
that but he said you know what it'll
take you two years to complete this
thesis maybe the best thing to do is put
your head down go through it I can
promise you that I'll offer you a
postdoc with me and Tel Aviv when you
get out and and you know you go to
another place there's a lot of respect
and she'll be starting all over
don't do that so I think that was good
advice and I did it there's a nice
little anecdote I don't know if it's in
the other book I you know I was of
course the whole time fuming internally
and when I finally submitted the thesis
actually there are two nice stories
about this if you don't have time bees
go ahead we like stories eyes are good
so one story is that that is the epigram
to the thesis when I finally submitted
it there's a quotation perhaps
apocryphal from Galileo
to the effect that when he was finally
released by the Vatican Inquisition he
stamped his foot on the ground after
having recanted his his doctrine that
the earth moves he he walked out of the
Vatican and stamped his foot on the
ground and said I think this is the
correct Italian said they pour si muove
a it moves it doesn't matter what I said
it moves anyway so I chose that quote in
Italian as the epigram for my thesis it
took the Department a couple of days to
figure out what and and there was
widespread offence and and and people
were upset the other nicer story is so I
submitted my thesis and as you know when
you do a defense people just to sort of
show that they've read the thesis people
never pass you completely outright they
say minor modifications you know
grammatical this or that you know you
know given minor modifications we pass
and you should submit the thesis to the
dean's office within a week or so so I
walked out of that defense in the in a
mood of the forum I'm not spending once
more second of my life you know looking
at this thesis or humoring these people
so I didn't so I never handed in the
final copy of my thesis to the dean's
office this was in 1981 and four years
afterwards there was a vague fear in the
back of my mind that somehow you know I
hadn't fulfilled the full technical
obligations for the PhD and somehow
someday God was going to use this to
punish me okay
so sure enough ten years later in 1990
I get a call from the librarian at
Rockefeller University who says you know
at the end of each decade we compile all
the theses completed over the course of
that decade into a bound volume and so
on and so forth and we find that we
don't have
a final copy of your thesis and I that
this was the call I had been having
nightmares about for ten years and I
froze in complete panic collected myself
a little bit and did something
uncharacteristically bald and you know
bold and sort of ballsy for me so I
collect myself and I say what you lost
my I mean what is your job anyway
besides keeping track of things like
this is outrageous this is unbelievable
I think this is appalling no I'm not
going to give you my final copy of my
thesis you had better turn that library
upside down and find that thesis and I
want to report within a week back from
you about what your progress has been in
finding the thesis the woman says I'm
sorry you're absolutely right gets off
the phone calls me back a week later and
tells me they found needs to say she was
referring to an item which I happen to
know did not exist yet and so that's a
nice story about my mind getting my face
and it's not as if you know you were
just rambling on at the time about what
could quantum mechanics mean her on of
and you you know wrote some very nice
papers at that time yeah they were
useful for physicists yeah as well yeah
no I I thought it was you know I had a
wonderful collaboration after that for
several years and in Israel with Aaron
oven just learned an enormous amount
from him I I don't know that I've ever
met anybody and this is different from
an intuition for how to solve
foundational problems I don't know that
I've ever met anyone in my life who had
as quick and as sure an intuitive grasp
which is almost a contradiction in terms
about how quantum mechanical systems are
going to behave and it was just amazing
and you know you'd be sitting in his
office he liked always to be talking to
people that's how he worked so we were
always
a couple of his graduate students and
postdocs were just sitting around in his
office in Tel Aviv all day and
discussing once again he wasn't so
focused on what I would now call
philosophical problems but he just had
this intuition about how you could make
quantum mechanical systems do
astonishing things there were stories
about him when he used to beat achieve
the University of New York where he
would walk into people's offices in the
philosophy department just in order to
have something to do that evening and
say describe a physical effect which is
obviously impossible you know some
people would say I don't know you know a
man turns into an elephant in our Senate
and Aronoff would go home and figure out
a quantum mechanical way that this could
happen and this is the this was the kind
of exercise that lay behind many things
that he discovered and again and again
he we would be talking about some
concrete physical example and he would
say it's gonna do this yeah and and you
would say how how do you know can you
explain he says I go home and do the
calculation it's obviously gonna do this
I don't know how to explain it and you
would go home and do the calculation
he'd be right it was astounding it was
one of these frustrating things also
because you figure if you're looking
right at him while he's doing it you're
gonna see how it does yeah Richard
Feynman's old desk at Caltech and I try
to hide you know blank pieces of paper
the right has coping they will appear
the next day so the problem that got you
on this path then presumably before this
moment you were a more or less
conventional theoretical physics
graduate student I think that's right
it's fair to say that my interests were
always in a foundational direction I I
mean I think I remember well maybe it's
too long a story yeah it to a first
approximation yes yes okay but then you
discovered that this or you started
thinking
the measurement problem of quantum
mechanics really deserved more scrutiny
or I mean I somehow I mean I'm sure many
people went through this this is nothing
extraordinary about me
I hadn't heard of the measurement
problem and and people often ask me to
reconstruct how exactly did you get from
reading young to the man from the
problem and and frankly I'm not able to
reconstruct that and it probably
involves an embarrassingly bad miss
reading of you yeah but he certainly was
not worried but somehow you know in the
course of a long night of great
intellectual excitement that began by
reading you by the time the Sun was
coming up I had understood that there
was a that there was a problem so how
would for our listeners who are not
physicists or philosophers how would you
say briefly what the measurement problem
is something like this if I ask how I
know there's a glass on the table in
front of us people are going to give an
account something like this well there's
light in the room and some of the light
reflects off the surface of the glass
and some of that reflected light enters
my eye and impacts my retina and causes
certain kinds of electrical excitations
there which in turn cause electrical
excitations in my optic nerve and deeper
into my brain and yada yada yada and
after however many steps such steps my
brain has entered the state associated
with the perception of a glass on the
table and I think it's fair to say that
although we don't know yet or might not
have known at the time what the detailed
physical laws were governing all those
steps the story had better end up going
something like that because we can't
imagine how else it might go and and
it's important that at the end of the
day we can convince ourselves that each
of those steps occurs in full accord
with whatever the fundamental physical
laws are and it's pretty easy to show
once you start thinking about it from
the right angle that this couldn't be
the correct account of how we of how we
know about the outcomes of certain
experiments on quantum mechanical
systems if we were to play the game of
imagining that the whole world is
governed by quantum mechanical laws at a
fundamental level and then it turns out
to be pretty easy to show and listeners
might find it surprising that this is
easy to show because thoughts may occur
like my god but a measuring device or a
brain is something that that's a
collection of trillions of of elementary
particles you can't possibly have solved
the equations of motion of all those now
it turns out that we don't need to we're
aware of a certain mathematical property
of those equations called linearity
which makes it easy for us to say given
that I have a device here which would
end up which would end up registering a
blip over there if there was a blip over
there and which would end up registering
a blip over there if there was a blip
over there
then we we have a way of calculating
pretty straightforwardly what it would
do in other circumstances so very
briefly in quantum mechanics or at least
on the standard way of thinking about
quantum mechanics material particles
like electrons for example can be in
familiar situations say where they're
located at Point a and other familiar
situations where they're located at
point B but they can also be in other
situations where they're all in in which
there are all kinds of compelling
experimental reasons to believe that
that the appropriate way of describing
them would be nothing like
that that you're in a situation in which
it would in which asking about the
spatial location of the electron would
be analogous to asking about the marital
status of the number-5 or about the
length and meters of Catholicism or
something like that something that
philosophers sometimes refer to as a
category mistake that that the electron
would be in a situation where it just
didn't make sense even to raise
questions about where it was located not
that it's located in a Poisson position
or other but we don't know which one but
like I say that's not what you would say
about the marital status of the number
five that I don't know what it is not I
reckon it's it there is no fact about
the about the marital status in the
number five good and it turns out that
you can show that what the quantum
mechanical equations of motion entail if
they applied to everything not merely
the electron whose position you're
measuring but the measuring device and
your brain when you look at the
measuring device and so on suggests that
if you were to interact with this
electron where the device designed to
measure its position the way things
would end up would be in a situation
where there fails to be a fact of the
matter about the direction in which the
pointer is pointing there fails to be a
fact of the matter about whether you're
in a brain state that that sees the
pointer pointing this way or that sees
the pointer pointing that right and the
idea is that these results these
implications of the equations of motion
seem to be as directly at odds as
anything could imaginably be with our
empirical experience of the world and
just to connect with because I think
some people probably have a little bit
of exposure to these ideas you're making
the point that there's no such thing as
the location of the electron in the
States what we often say is that the
electron is in a superposition a
different location exactly so we can't
help but where we deny Eve we follow the
rules of
mechanics end up in a superposition of
brains day that's right that what I
sometimes say to students is that what
the linearity of the quantum mechanical
equations of motion and tail is that
this condition of being super posed in
this way turns out to be fantastically
infectious you touch it and you've got
it - okay and yet we never feel like
we're in a superposition from sense and
so that's the measurement problem so
that's one way of saying the measurement
problem I guess right or a stronger way
of saying it although of course I know
you're anticipating things to come in in
putting it the way you did but the
initial reaction was more like it's test
not just that we don't feel that it's
obvious that that's not the state it
doesn't okay it's obvious that it
doesn't happen
we are assure that that doesn't happen
as we are of anything what happens in a
laboratory is that we go and look at
these pointers and we end up with a
perfectly determinate belief about where
the pointer is pointing in situations
like that which belief we end up with is
usually a matter of chance it's either
here or there the trouble is that what
the quantum mechanical equations of
motion predict is first of all that
there's no chance at all that the
evolution of the world is completely
deterministic and second of all that the
state that you deterministically end up
in is one in which they're emphatically
fails to be a fact of the matter about
which way the pointer is pointing or
about which way you think the pointer is
pointing and as I said the usual
reaction to this is not oh that's funny
that's not the way we usually feel it
was stronger than that this is obviously
false yeah
but in fact it was so obviously false
that the idea of simply taking seriously
the quantum mechanical equations the
Schrodinger equation never occurred to
the inventors of quantum mechanics right
so the debates between Einstein and Bohr
and others back in the 1920s and 30s and
so on led to this additional set of
rules which we now call the Copenhagen
interpretation right what are your
thoughts on the company it's a it's well
we could say what it is wave functions
collapse etcetera that's I mean so but
the first
to say about it and and the book by one
of the many virtues of the book by Adam
Becker that you mentioned earlier is
that he points out that as a historical
matter a you know the the the words
Copenhagen interpretation don't really
refer to any single internally coherent
set of claims different people claim to
be enunciated the Copenhagen
interpretation when they were actually
saying quite different things but yeah
the the thing you referred to I think
it's fair to say is the is the thing
that was standing there once all the
dust settled after many years and it's
it's it's a it's a claim like this that
gee if you really bite the bullet here
what you've got to say is that
apparently there are two fundamental
laws of the evolution of the physical
state of the world
one of which the one that sort of has
sovereignty over the world in those
situations when a measurement is not
going on are these linear equations of
motion and the other which is in force
when measurements are going on is
something called the collapse postulate
which which selects out one or the other
of these possibilities for you makes it
the case that when you measure the
position of an electron which is in a
superposition of being at x and y that
the measurement sort of has two steps
the idea of its being a passive thing
vanishes forever from physics step one
although these aren't things that occur
at two different times but there are two
conceptual steps step one is it changes
the situation of the electron from one
in which its you know there is no fact
about where it is to one in which there
is a fact about where it is and then
reports to you what that fact is the
minute this was proposed it was
obviously wildly inadequate or at least
fell wildly short of our previous
for physics it involved at the
fundamental level an English word
measurement okay things behave
differently when a measurement is going
on and when a measurement is not going
on and it was clear that this English
word or the German word in von neumann's
book where this was first clearly laid
out didn't have anything approaching the
requisite precision to play that kind of
a role in a fundamental physical account
of the world so that minute this was
proposed and I don't know what it was
exactly in von neumann's mind but the
minute it was proposed it was obviously
some kind of bad joke okay or it was
something that demanded it was a
provisional placeholder kind of thing
that demanded much much more elaboration
what's astonishing is that for I think
it's fair to say so anoying ins book was
written I think at the very beginning of
the thirties yeah 35 mm for the next
half century the-the-the the way that
thought about this subject proceeded was
by people going in what they should have
realized from the beginning were
ridiculous circles so people would
propose people a project grew up of
locating exactly being able to delineate
exactly the location of the boundary
between that set of circumstances where
one of these laws applied and that set
where other of the laws applied so words
like measurement were replaced by other
words like macroscopic or
thermodynamically irreversible or an
indelible versus an indelible recording
or subject an object or something like
that and these were all everybody should
have realized you know within two
seconds that there was no improvement
going on here at all that all of these
words were equally vague but even these
words were invoked by at best a minority
of working physicists most working
physicians didn't care today
are very happy to just right right but
it also I I think there may have been a
symbiosis there it gave the business of
speculating about this a well-deserved
bad reputation I mean perhaps the most
famous of these speculations was one due
to Vigna who was a of course very
prominent and well-known physicist of
the first half of the 20th century
person widely credited with introducing
group theory into physics and thinking
about symmetries in a certain way into
physics and so on Nobel prize-winner so
on and so forth
thought that the way to draw the line
between these two domains of of
situations in the world was depended on
whether or not they involved conscious
systems indeed there's a essay that that
you know listeners might be interested
to look at a famous essay of ignorant
problem where he's thrilled about this
idea for the following reason it's been
thought for a long time that the picture
of the world we get from physics is
hostile to certain ideas we have about
ourselves as agents and as thinkers
there's no room in this picture for mind
there's no room in this picture for
agency or freedom so on and so forth
vintner thought vikner had this idea
that it was precisely conscious agency
that caused departures from the standard
quantum mechanical equations of motion
that caused the collapse of the
wavefunction indeed he thought there was
in this a new definition of the
difference between in animate and
inanimate physical objects what you mean
by an inanimate physical object is
precisely one that evolves according to
the standard quantum mechanical
equations of motion and animate ones are
ones that don't that can give rise to
collapse as a wave function and vigorous
thought this was great
because physics had for so long seemed
hostile to the idea of a non-physical
mind somewhere in the world it turns out
so he thought not only is it not hostile
it requires such a thing in order to do
its ordinary physical job good obviously
this distinction between animate and
inanimate is just as vague as anything
else I remember I you know I swear on
anything you want me to swear on that as
a graduate student I witnessed Vigna at
a conference in response to a question
speculating to the effect that that he
thought dogs could likely collapse
wavefunctions but mice probably not say
you sit there and you say this is not
good okay this is not the way to do
physics so it remained in that kind of
terrible state for about 40 years in the
meantime sorry to be SuperDuper fair
since in a few minutes I'm gonna be
advocating that every time you do a
quantum measurement the world's puts
more multiple copies it's not the
ridiculousness of the claim that worries
us much is the vagueness absolutely
right
yes I think that's I think that's a good
point but the the business of having
debates between you know about dogs
versus mice emphasizes just that pride
one right yeah let gee who's gonna lie
you got win that argument right you know
that's right right I agree with you okay
very basically for about 50 years after
von Neumann that's where things stood
during that period there were at least
two what would later be recognized as
very important developments one due to
Everett which you were just referring to
and another due to David Bohm which were
serious attempt to to make sense of this
problem but they were completely ignored
by at the time then finally also in the
early eighties there was a third
suggestion due to girardi Romanian Weber
which was along the lines of the
collapse theory and at that point it's
fair to say there began to be a critical
mass of people talking about this and so
on somebody else very much worth
mentioning who was belongs mostly to the
earlier period is John Bell who did take
note of bums work who did take note of
everett's work and I think who was
widely thought of nowadays as the person
who in contrast to all the other people
we were talking about before Vigna and
the macroscopic people and the
thermodynamic reversibility people Bell
is widely regarded as the person who
showed how to think through these
questions correctly who established a
sort of criterion as to what kind of
thing could even be counted as a
potential answer to this problem
and what couldn't and how you would
begin to evaluate them relative to one
another he really set the field in a
kind of order that I think the the
useful and productive parts of it have
been following ever since right so we
have the measurement problem there's
this weird thing that if you take the
quantum mechanical equations by which
you know Schrodinger's equation is the
most obvious version but they're sort of
different ways of writing it if you take
those seriously we seem to run into a
conflict with experience with what we
see about the world that we that it says
that we should ourselves evolve into
super positions right so you've
mentioned these three different ways of
tackling that problem we don't have to
be historical we can be logical you're a
favorite way of introducing the planner
of know of introducing the platter yeah
Bell nicely said in a paper that what
the measurement problem shows is that
either the Schrodinger
poison isn't everything or it isn't
right okay now your favorite
interpretation is going to deny both of
those but this is a good way to begin to
understand what's going on the thought
was either we need to so there was this
way the standard way of representing
states of quantum mechanical systems
that came along with quantum mechanics
quantum mechanical wave function of the
quantum mechanical state vector that
vector
you know unambiguously ends up a certain
way at the end of the measurement
process and it ends up in a way that
doesn't contain information about what
the result of the measurement was and
indeed on the standard way of
interpreting it denied that there was a
fact about what the outcome of the
measurement was Bell said look there are
two ways I can imagine dealing with this
one changed the equations okay change
the equations such that they do evolve
this weight wavefunction or state vector
in such a way that it ends up associated
with one or another particular outcome
of this experiment indeed among the
things you would have to change about
the laws of evolution is that they
presumably no longer be deterministic
they're now going to be stochastic
because our experience is that sometimes
you get this result and sometimes you
get that that's one strategy that's
referred to as as writing down a theory
of the collapse of the wavefunction this
is the strategy that's most continuous
with the kind of thing that von Neumann
was originally imagining there's another
and dis parenthetically even though it
doesn't get that much attention among
philosophers of foundations Roger
Penrose his efforts are in this
direction that's correct
explicit theory of the collapse of the
wave thats correct and we might talk
later I think I think there are reasons
why grw strategy is probably better than
Penrose mataji grw being three guys have
a different theory of the collateral
but that's right Penn roses is another
theory in this family or within this
tradition so that's tradition number one
tradition number two is to take the
other horn of the dilemma that bell
spells out it might be that the standard
laws of the evolution of this quantum
mechanical wave function that we have
are perfectly true but the wave function
itself might not amount to a complete
description of the physical situation
you have to add other variables these
variables for unfortunate historical
reasons were called hidden variables but
if you study something like bombs theory
they're the opposite of hidden they're
the thing you see right and Einstein had
sympathies along this device yes he did
that's right that's right that's what he
seemed to want and that's what the the
EPR paradox appears to be an argument
for and most people would say that the
best example we currently have of a
theory along those lines although also
there there are several is is one due to
David Bohm in the in the 1950s there's a
you know said I mean I mean the story as
you hinted at and I don't want to get
too sidetracked here of the way this
work was ignored and the mechanisms that
allowed the theoretical physics to meet
community to ignore them are are sad and
in many ways appalling in the case of
Bohm in particular one of the things
that allowed people to ignore his work
was the work of the McCarthy Committee
in the 50s he was harassed out of the
country soon after
publishing his theory that was something
that made it much easier to ignore his
work there's a I've often thought
somebody like Becker begins to make a
stab at this I've often thought that if
you were to trace the sort of the
history of people's reactions to
foundational problems of quantum
mechanics you know you'd get a whole
underground history of the 20th century
and all kinds of forces come into it
McCarthyism comes into it in in Russia
you know dialectical materialism comes
into it
the rise of modernism in the beginning
of the twenty twentieth century comes
into it it would be a very interesting
story to trace out in detail but anyway
that's a side issue then there is this
other more radical more heroic more
exciting tradition of Everett which
wants to the third-order of the dilemma
the third Horn of the dilemma which Bell
doesn't anticipate in this in the
description I just referred to where
you're going to insist no the quantum
mechanical wave function is a complete
description of nature and moreover the
the the standard linear quantum
mechanical equations of motion without
the collapse are always obeyed and how
do I want to put this the Bell excuse me
not Bell Everett suggested in his paper
and the paper is at a couple of points
crucially unclear this was apparently
not Everett's fault but the fault of his
is very unresponsible in this case
thesis adviser John Wheeler who muddied
and dulled Everett's point all over the
place because he was afraid of Bohr's
reaction
indeed there are I just recently read
Becker's book so I'm referring to it a
lot
there are astonishing letters in
Becker's book that I'd never seen before
of bore of wheeler trying to sort of you
know assure Bohr that that ever it
wasn't really criticizing him that you
know could have been lifted out of a
Soviet show trial or I mean it's just it
just mind-boggling yeah I mean there are
two things that struck me because I'm
read Adams book and many other things
for writing my own book and so Everett
was a graduate student of John wheeler
and wheeler himself had worked with it
wasn't the student of but had been
advised and mentored by Niels Bohr who
was the granddaddy of the Copenhagen
interpreter and one you know like you
say is that the the reaction was both
from wheeler who was afraid I don't know
I don't know if afraid is the right word
but certainly reluctant right in a very
explicit way of crossing Bohr and
everyone else in the Copenhagen but also
the many letters that came back and
forth from Bohr's acolytes in Copenhagen
right
some of them directly to Everett are in
just being so dismissive and so
misunderstanding in it and you you feel
bad for Everett but the other one is
that you know ever it as someone who
made this contribution as a graduate
student and then left the field and did
other things
there's his times in physics when
someone does something great because
they were in the right place at the
right time not necessarily because they
were the smartest person around right
but he read you know whatever it's
writing and he was the smartest person
Hannity sure he understood all of the
implications of what he was saying I
think that's right and you know he left
academia because he wanted to leave a
cube Ramius right as far as I can I
think I think that's right and the flip
side of this there is this horror of the
way Bohr ruled things the flip side I
must say you know he's one of the people
if I could pick to meet a historical
figure because he must have been the
most somehow the most charismatic human
being in the history of the world
and there was just this
long string of brilliant people who
would spend an hour with Bohr their
entire lives would be changed and one of
the ways in which their lives were
changed is that they were spouting
gibberish you know that was completely
beneath them about the foundations of
quantum mechanics for the rest of their
lives and you want to know how did this
guy do this and they revered in him you
get a quote from wheeler saying like the
thing that made me convinced that there
were people that's racist and I mean
it's just meeting Niels Bohr just you
know boy do I want to meet this good
because it doesn't come across and is
right it doesn't come across in his
writing at all at all you know there is
what's usually advertised as the as the
most detailed an elaborate and sustained
statement of Bohr's view is his response
to the pr paper and anybody who's tried
to read this it's just really hard to
see what's going on and I don't know if
you've heard this story but a couple of
years ago Shelley Goldstein happened to
discover I can see by your face that you
don't know this story this is an amazing
story that the standard version of borås
response to the EPR the one that was
almost exclusively the template for
every reprinting it reprinting of it
over a period of about 50 years had two
of the pages reversed nobody ever
noticed this okay so you have you know
anybody my age your age probably a
little less has had a long history of
the minute you bring up of worry about
the foundations of quantum mechanics
people say I why do I have to waste my
time on this Bohr settled all those
figured it out a long time ago and you
say to them great could you tell me what
he says and they say no go read the
paper okay and it's obvious that none of
the people who were saying this ever
read the paper okay yeah it's just
mind boggle okay yeah and there's a
whole bunch of other anecdotes we
encourage people to read Adam Becker's
book we'll have at him on the podcast at
some point it's a it's a fascinating
history of the foundations of quantum
mechanics which is an understudy field
so let's do
Everett first because it's my favorite
so what was Everett's solution so the
way that quantum mechanics
mathematically depicts these states of
an electron for example in which there
fails to be any fact of the matter about
whether it's located at a or located at
B is by means of an addition of two
vectors the superposition of being at a
and B is represented by the state vector
associated with being at point A plus
the state vector associated with being
at point B and the the kind of state
that the equations of motion predict
that you're going to be in at the end of
one of these measurement processes looks
like a state in which the electron is a
and the measuring device registers it to
be a and the sentient observer sees it
to be a plus the state where it's at B
and the measuring device registers it to
be at the and the observer sees that it
be and this is nice way to put it
because it really drives home the
difference with classical mechanics
right in classical mechanics an electron
can be a day or a via B there's no such
thing for F being at a plus B for us
it's not a thing because there's a lot
of mechanics you can take any two states
and add that absolutely Randy in the
Superman and be in some distinct
physical state that has its own
distinctive physical properties so
Everett's idea was to interpret the kind
of state that I was just describing
speaking crudely here and he was more
careful than this but we want to be a
little fast here
as one in which there were two observers
or two experiences of the world being
depicted okay in one of which there is a
particle at a and there is a measuring
device that registers it to be a day and
there's an observer who sees it a day
and then the other of which there is a
particle at B and a measuring device
that registers it to be at B and and an
observer who sees it to be at B or who
knows it to be at B and that in some
sense they were really two things there
there are as it were two internally
coherent stories or worlds going on
there
and it follows immediately that of
course we wouldn't be aware of this kind
of splitting because our mental state is
either seeing it at a and not it be
you're seeing it at vien and not a day
so Everett's idea was maybe there is a
way to take exactly what the standard
quantum mechanical formalism had always
said literally maybe the arguments that
we were referring to before to the
effect that we know this not to be what
happens at the conclusion of the
measurement process is wrong it's ever
it often compared it in what I always
thought was a very nice metaphor with
with consequences of Newtonian mechanics
okay
and Newtonian mechanics has what seems
at first like the very counterintuitive
prediction that the earth is in motion
that it's moving very quickly and you
know one is tenth one one we tend to
objected first that's impossible we
would fall off someone and so you would
feel it right and and Newton or I don't
know what the history is but but
Newtonian mechanics has the resources to
respond to that by saying no you haven't
worked out the problem to the end it
turns out that the very same laws that
predict that the earth is in motion
predict also that if that were true you
would think it wasn't okay if that were
true you wouldn't feel it and something
very much like that is being done with
the linearity of the quantum mechanical
equations of motion in the case of
Everett this same linearity that leads
to this very puzzling an apparently
false prediction of superposition okay
also predicts that if that were what was
going on you wouldn't know it right
you would think otherwise you would as a
matter of physics as a matter of your
physical behavior you would testify to
the contrary if you were interviewed
about it so there is a sort of very
exciting very pure very radical you know
an early fan of Everett was Sidney
Coleman at Harvard who used to go around
giving a lecture that I thought was very
aptly named about Everett
it was called quantum mechanics in your
face and the idea was no no it doesn't
need to be pretty DUP or ugly duck or
something like that it doesn't need to
be dressed up or modified take the thing
completely at face value but calm down
and interpret it carefully and precisely
and you'll see that what it's depicting
you'll see of locating you'll see a way
of locating in it exactly your empirical
experience of the world okay let me
let's put aside one can talk about the
many-worlds interpretation for hours but
I want to skip over the boring parts
there are what I consider to be
hilariously unconvincing objections to
the Everett interpretation like I just
don't like all those world's kinds of
things right right and there's also what
I you have objections like that physics
isn't the field for you gonna be playing
in your face or intuition right there
are also what I take to be convincing
arguments for Everett there's a sales
pitch that I like to give let's take
both of those
into as if they were on the table and
move on because I think that your
attitude is you wouldn't object to ever
it in the same way you've checked to
Copenhagen just because it's vague and
ill-defined right you just don't think
it quite works yeah that's right that's
right
I mean basically look and preparatory to
this I don't wanna even though it might
enhance the excitement of the podcast I
don't want to be more dogmatic here than
I actually oh you know that's right I'm
not playing a role
let's try truth right so so you know
what's the so that having been said let
me say what I take the situation to be
there's a very obvious puzzle about
effort which goes like which can be
brought up very easily although when you
try to participate gets complicated in
all kinds of interesting ways but
crudely speaking you say look quantum
mechanics as it's usually formulated is
a chancy theory it's a probabilistic
theory
moreover that's not merely a sort of
curious feature of it a peripheral
feature or an unimportant feature
it's absolutely at its core the reasons
we think we have the empirical reasons
we think we have for believing that
quantum mechanics is true have to do
with experiments that we repeat many
times and and obtain results in terms of
large frequencies that we think bear out
those probabilistic predictions
those probabilistic predictions that
chance eNOS is absolutely at the heart
of what we take to be our compelling
reasons for believing that the theory is
true in the first place and and the
obvious question that comes up right
away is that look if if Everett is
telling us he's got a way of
understanding
the deterministic equations of motion to
be true under all circumstances there's
just a very prima facie tension between
the claim that the laws of the evolution
of the world are completely
deterministic and the appearance of
these pervasive chance eNOS Azure
probabilities in our experience that on
the most primitive level as a sort of
you know first pass is what's puzzling
is is one of the things that's puzzling
not in terms like you say of being of
being unexpected or surprising or
counterintuitive but on the level of
coherence yeah okay if this theory is
supposed to explain our experience how
does it explain our experience of these
chances I mean at the very least both
people Pro and anti ever agree that the
usual way of talking in quantum
mechanics that there is a probability of
30% I will see the spin ah right can't
be exactly right right it might be maybe
you talk as if that's true right be it
gets you through the day but what
actually happens is that with 100%
probability you evolve into multiple
people correct correct
so there were there's a long history of
trying a various I think very
imaginative ways and ways from which
we've learned a lot about the question
of what probability talk means more
generally of trying to come to terms
with this there there was an attitude
which is now more or less forgotten but
I think was very clever this was
certainly for example Sydney Coleman's
attitude and other people's attitude
that they pointed out that something
that was a feature of these
deterministic equations of motion is
that if you did an experiment say
measuring the Z spin of an electron that
started out with a definite spin in the
X direction and our experience of those
measurements is that half the time they
come out
spent up half the time they come out Z
spin down you you just look at the
equations of motion how they describe a
situation in which you repeated an
experiment like that many many times and
it turns out you can prove a theorem
very easily that as the number of times
call it in that you've repeated that
experiment goes to infinity the world
approaches a funny state in which even
though there is no fact of the matter
about how any individual one of those
experiments came out there is a factor
of the matter and this seems like almost
like a contradiction there is a
perfectly definite fact of the matter
about the proportion of them that came
out up and the proportion of them that
came out down and in the limit as n goes
to infinity that proportion approaches
exactly one half and and lots of people
were seduced and excited by by this
result did effort himself have been
argument along those I think he did I
think you know it's a little like I say
wasn't included in there that's right
I haven't you know something I need to
do and have never done is read all the
original everett stuff which is now
available although only pretty recently
in the published part of his work that
argument isn't really clear but I agree
with you about in your assessment of
Everett's brilliance and I would suspect
he was he was aware of that argument and
he was just obliged to hide it from Bohr
because it was too good but we have
other arguments now people are still
trying right so anyway that for various
reasons didn't work out I mean I guess
one of the things to say about it is
that before you actually do get to the
limit the theory is adamant that there
are no facts about anything okay and we
don't in fact do infinite numbers of
experiments and so on so there were
those things since then I think it's
probably fair to say that in like the
late seventies through the early 90s
there was less excitement than there is
now about this interpretation and I
think a lot of it was due to this
difficulty of seeing how you could make
sense of probability talk since then
there's been a very interesting and very
lively revival of attempts to make sense
out of that probability talks and there
are two big traditions that have come up
one tradition which is associated with
names like David Deutsch and David
Wallace and lots of people around Oxford
something that's funny and noticeable
about foundations of quantum mechanics
is that even though all of us grew up
with telephones and and so on and so
forth attitudes about the foundations
are incredibly geographically it's not
as well defined and and Oxford was for
many years the sort of isolated
epicenter of sympathy to the Eveready in
view anyway there is a view that goes
like this you start out by saying okay
you're right that is you say to the
critics you're right there are no
probabilities here I take it back you
won't hear me use the word probability
anymore okay they say take it seriously
that the only correct thing to say about
what's going to happen to you when you
make this measurement is that you're
gonna split okay you're gonna split in
this particular way pose the following
question suppose that you knew that
that's what was going to happen to you
how would it be rational for you to
behave okay what kinds of bets would it
would be rational for you to accept or
decline so on and so forth and these
guys claimed to have an argument and I
think it's an argument that doesn't work
and maybe we'll get a chance to talk
about it a little bit but they claim to
have an argument that it just so happens
that in a world like that a rat the
kinds of bets that a rational agent
would accept or decline would just
happen to be exactly the same ones that
she would accept or decline in a
completely different universe which was
chancy ok which which had something like
the von Neumann picture and so the idea
was you're right there are no chances
but the roles the chances actually play
in our lives both in our practical lives
and in our cognitive lives are are more
or less exhausted by these claims about
which bets we would make and what we've
got here is a different universe than
the one we thought we were in a fully
deterministic universe where we know
what's going to happen but where it just
so happens we can show that if you were
if you took yourself to be in a universe
like this the kinds of vets you would
make the kinds of decisions you would
make about how to behave would be
exactly as if you were in a different
Chansey universe and it's that match
that's all that we mean when we say the
universe is Chauncey in a way that it
appears to us to be I mean if it's
possible I would love to hear the germ
of your objection to this so here's the
germ of my objection I'll try to say it
will will achieve some compromise
between saying and clearly and saying it
concisely and maybe I'll try to say it
concisely first in in you killin make it
make me say it more clearly concisely
it's this these strategies all depend
that these arguments depend on so that
the kinds of things these arguments
purport
to show is that you know if you have if
you want to do any kind of decision
series so there's a whole branch of
logic and mathematics and philosophy
called decision theory where people try
to sort of ax Emmett eyes and lay down
clearly what it means to make a rational
decision and in order to know what
decision you need to make there are
certain you need to decide in advance
something you wish to maximize you may
wish to maximize longevity or happiness
or profit or something like that but
given a decision about what you wish to
maximize and given some picture you have
about how the world works what kinds of
application at what kinds of actions
have what kinds of probabilities of
leading to what kinds of results there's
an algorithm that people try to develop
and decision theory that you can feed
all this into and decide what you what
you want to do the axioms seem fairly
unobjectionable like if you prefer A to
B and B to C you prefer ATIS right so on
and so forth there's a there's a nice
old joke which it's worth bringing up of
Sydney mortgage investors who used to be
in the philosophy department at Columbia
Sydney said what is it the maximizing
Jewish decision theory answer regret
[Laughter]
anyway the thought of these decision
theoretic arguments for Everett is as
follows we take your preferences for
cases where the world is not going to
branch you prefer the outcome to be more
money rather than less money for you or
something like that and the structure of
all the arguments is given your
preferences for non-branching futures
given your preferences among
non-branching futures we can derive on
pain of irrationality what preferences
you must have among branching futures
so given the amount of money that you're
willing to pay to make some
non-branching future come true we're
going to be able to deduce on pain of
irrationality how much money you'd be
willing to pay in order to have a
certain branching future come true and
what they claim to be able to show is
that the amount of money you would pay
to have this branching future come true
is exactly the amount you would pay to
have one branch come true with a certain
probability and have the other branch
country with a certain probability good
in a very concise statement of the
objection and this sounds very simple
and it's amazing
how long it took for people to see it
because the arguments were couched in a
way that made it hard to see look it's
just nuts to think that your preferences
among non-branching futures could in any
way constrain on pain of straightforward
irrationality your your preferences
among branching futures the branching
futures are a whole new set of flavors
available to you that become available
only once you start considering so for
example you may be somebody who under
normal circumstances I don't know what
prefers chocolate ice cream to vanilla
ice cream but if you're suddenly offered
a new option ah
there can be two of you one of them them
has chocolate ice cream one of them has
vanilla ice cream you might be at you
might have a taste for a variety or
something like that
which is simply not going to show up in
any of your non-branching preferences
okay so there is and I think when you
put it this way the whole strategy
becomes obviously nuts okay there there
you're not going to have on pain of
irrationality you may think these tastes
are weird and so on that's not what
decision theories about like we were
saying you can choose to maximize
anything you want profit longevity
regret
you know whatever you like okay the
decision theory is just supposed to tell
you what you're supposed to do these
guys are arguing that once we know your
non-branching preferences unless you're
completely irrational we all we also
know you're branching preferences the
idea that that just couldn't be right
okay
that couldn't possibly be right because
once the branching preferences are put
on the table oh you can choose among
these two you got a whole bunch of
different stuff to choose between the
thought was that your preferences among
branching cases must somehow leave a
trace or show up among your
non-branching preferences in a way
that's sufficiently strong to fully
constrain your preferences among the
branching cases I think this is just
wrong okay let me see if I can give a
more concrete example so the here's a
standard example which people in the
decision theoretic tradition use imagine
the following kind of superposition you
have a hundred dollars and the rest of
the world is in state a okay
and you have one dollar and the rest of
the world is in state B okay imagine the
superposition of those two you have a
hundred dollars and the rest of the
world is in state a plus you have one
dollar and the rest of the world is in
state B good moreover let it be
stipulated that among the non-branching
options that is you have a hundred
dollars you have one dollar you don't
care about the rest of the world you
only care about how much money you have
so you have no preferences among you
have a hundred dollars in the world is
in state a and you have a hundred
dollars in the world is in state B and
you have no preferences among you have
one dollar in the world is in state a
and wandering the world is in state B
but you prefer a hundred dollars with a
or b any state with 100
is whether the world rest of the world
is in state a or state B to any state
with one dollar and the rest of the
world is in state a or state be good
then they say suppose that's true
now consider the following two super
positions $100 and state a plus $1 and
state B and $100 in state B plus $1 in
state a they say you couldn't have a
preference for one of those over the
other because you've already made it
clear that you don't care about the
difference between a and B that's what
shows up and you're in your
non-branching preferences yeah okay kind
of makes sense to me good good so let's
so let's go let me actually to make this
even more clear let me back up a tiny
bit well I'll go through it here and
then maybe we'll back up when we need to
right okay yeah okay suppose I say you
know part of the state of the rest of
the world is in state a on fat and in
state B I'm thin okay I don't care about
how fat I am
that is what I mean by I don't care how
fat I am is I have no preferences
between $100 in fact and $100 in thin
and I prefer $100 fat or thin to $1.00
fat or thin so I have no preferences
about my way but I say now I'm
confronted with the branching
preferences and I say you know I think I
kind of like to be rich in the branch
where I'm fat because I think more of me
is going to be there okay or something
now we don't have to have a discussion
about how reasonable this so you think
it's a logical possibility there's a lot
but that's that's recondition alized on
the exam one woman exactly okay
it was always and you're familiar with
this example you use this example in
some papers of yours for slightly
different reasons but everybody thought
and it seemed very innocent to say of
course it's not gonna matter if you
permute the fat and thin you've already
told us you don't care about that
they weren't careful to attend to the
fact that what they meant by saying
you've already told us you don't care
about that is that it doesn't show up in
your non-branching preferences nothing
about you know you're having those
non-branching preferences is completely
consistent with your having all kinds of
different preferences among different
kinds of branching that might occur ok
so I just think and and the minute you
start to think about it that way it
seems to me you immediately said
yourself my god what could we have been
thinking of course the branching
preference is just a whole new set of
options that you have
once those are put on the table what
makes you imagine that you could have
deduced as a matter you know on pain of
pure and consistency your preference is
among the branching options just from
your much more limited set of
preferences among the highly special
non-branching options so that's in a
nutshell why I think those arguments
don't work do they have an obvious
response to this yet is this the ongoing
dialogue there is I think it's fair to
say there's an ongoing dialogue and I
don't want to put words in people's
mouths there are various other
principles that are sometimes cited in
decision theories things that go under
names like die chronic coherence and so
on and so forth which are sometimes
people try to bring to bear in these
situations I think they're beside the
point
yeah I wouldn't say that anybody's given
up and rolled over although I do think
for example David Wallace's claims about
what this kind of argument establishes
are now a little bit more
then then they used to be that they're
clearly showing the consistency of such
a thing right but not necessarily the
rational necessity of such a thing but I
don't want to put words again David's
mouth that's my impression it has gone
back and forth their attempts to justify
some of these principles from myself and
it took me a while you know in my the
evolution of my own thinking about this
I had thought of this I had thought of
this so-called fatness example early on
it took me a while to see the general
point okay
the general point that now see is these
branching options like these
non-branching options are just a tiny
fraction of the actual options you have
once branching is put on the table weird
where did you get the idea that you
could infer everything about your
preferences among the branching cases
from your preferences among the
non-branching yeah because I think I've
read stuff by you about the fatness
example right I found it wholly
unconvincing why is this point makes
perfect sense to me that there can just
be correlations between preferences that
couldn't have existed that's wrong
branding that's right that's right
so so I think that's a much cleaner way
to make the point and as you just said
this wasn't the way I presented it in
earlier writings I had very specific
examples now you know it took a while to
understand that these are examples of a
very general very simple point and and
and I don't know if that point has been
made in writing in such a way that it's
really gotten the attention of advocates
of this point of view and maybe we'll
just have to wait a little to see to see
how it strikes then speaking of waiting
a little we're clearly not gonna do
justice to grw & Bone that's okay right
some other day we will we might as well
do justice to Everett said there's
another way to get the probability sure
you also don't agree with sure that
there's a there's a way so and here's
where I want to be a little less
dogmatic
I think there's a pretty cut-and-dried
argument as I've just been describing
against the decision theoretic point of
view there is a point of view that's
associated with among other people you
about this that I've been thinking about
for much less long because it's been
proposed more recently and I met at
least at this stage more puzzled about
but I but it's fair to say that I have
worries about it that looked to me to be
serious so so if you want me to describe
I do
sorry I'll chime in so it's something
like this the original that one of the
original ways we had of putting the
worry was look where does or admit maybe
I didn't put it this way but here's a
way of putting it at this stage of the
discussion that'll be useful
we're about to do a measurement of the Z
spin of an electron whose ex spin is
definite or we're about to do a
measurement of the position maybe that's
easier to understand of a particle which
is being in a super which is in at the
moment the superposition of being
located at X and located at Y and we say
look if ever it is true I know exactly
what's going to happen there are gonna
be two of me one of them is gonna see
the the particle that X one of them is
going to see the particle and y end of
story
everything is deterministic and what's
puzzling about this is as follows if you
consider any other circumstances in
which we've found it sensible to say
things like the probability that X is
going to occur or the probability that
I'm going to see X is 50% say now we
don't have a fully satisfactory
consensus on a correct philosophical
analysis of chance but sure as hell
whatever it means
one of the things that implies is that
there's something about the future of
which I'm not currently certain okay
there may be any number of reasons for
my not being certain about this aspect
of the future it may be that the
fundamental laws of motion are
inherently chancy and for that reason I
can't be certain about the future no
matter how much information I may have
about the present or it may be that the
laws are perfectly deterministic but
there's some information about the
present that I'm missing because it's
very difficult to obtain because it's
very microscopically detailed or
something like that and it may be some
combination of those two factors the
worry in the Everett cases there seems
to be nothing relevant to what I'm
interested in here about the future when
I'm preparing to do this measurement of
the position of the particle there seems
to be nothing relevant about the future
of which I'm currently ignorant I know
exactly what's gonna happen there gonna
be these two guys one will see the
particle at x1 will see the particle at
Y end of story
so you say where does anything like
chance have an opportunity to get a
foothold chance requires uncertainty
okay remember and it's helpful here to
contrast this with the decision
theoretic strategy the decision
theoretic strategy took the following
route we agree there's no room for a
chance here there's no chance here all
that's going on is that the decisions
that a rational person is going to make
would be the same ones they would make
under these other circumstances where
there is chance so call it pseudo chance
or something like that good here's
another approach somebody says let's
look at this process in a little more
detail imagine that there is an interval
between the measurement actually being
carried out and my looking at the
measuring device but I know that the
measurement has already been carried out
before I look at the measuring device at
that point it seems fair to say
I know that I'm now already either in
the electron was at point-a world or I'm
in the electron that was in point-b
world but I don't know which so here it
seems as if we have the sort of thing we
wanted we have some genuine uncertainty
once we've got uncertainty about the
future that is I don't know which one
I'm going to see when I look it feels
like chance has a chance to get a
foothold in a in an odd incoherent way
there are all kinds of questions which
we could discuss in more detail okay but
who says we always have this interval
and and in some sense is in this
interval coming too late and too late in
the game put put those all aside because
I think you guys have interesting things
to say about all of those us guys being
in the paper I wrote was with chip cbins
that's right now I collaborated my
colleague at Caltech right right in the
philosophy department chance back in the
game in contrast to the decision
theoretic strategy there is something
you don't know rush which branch will
leave from right neuron right
good here's what it's hard for me to
understand about this this comes out of
a tradition of thinking about
probabilities epistemic lis okay of
thinking that what probabilities
represent our cases of us being ignorant
about something let me think about
what's the right order in which to say
stuff here
the the
let me say it in this order so there a
couple of things that there are a couple
of things that I find puzzling piled on
top of each other here the piling makes
them that much more puzzling as a
collective the first thing is there is
this long tradition of thinking this
tradition that goes back to Laplace if I
know if what I know and all I know is
that either there's a marble in box a or
there's a marble in Box B and I know
nothing more
that is my epistemic situation with
regard to the question is the marble in
box a or box B is I have no clue then
there is some kind of a priori principle
of rationality to the effect that the
probability you ought to assign to the
marble being unbox a is 50% and the
probability you ought to assign to its
being in Box B is 50% this is referred
to as a principle of indifference and
the aspect of it I want to focus on is
not exactly how you do the calculation
because you guys are going to have
different ways of doing it you're gonna
have your ESP principle you can have
different ways of doing it there the
important feature of it is that it's a
priori okay but it's a that it Oracle
that's right it's not empirical it
enters in is a principle of rationality
and there's something very confusing to
me about a strategy like that there is
that is when people are asked to offer
arguments for a strategy like this there
is a fairly straightforward argument
well look there is a certain symmetry in
my epistemic situation my epistemic
situation doesn't distinguish in any way
shape or form between box a and box B so
when I come to the business of assigning
probabilities in order to be faithful in
order for these probabilities to be
faithful representations of my epistemic
situation they must respect these
symmetries that are inherent in my
epistemic situation and there is only
one assignment that
probabilities that respects those
symmetries in a case like this it's the
50-50 okay and it seems to me that one's
reaction to this ought to be and then
mind you I mean you go back in the
history people use this kind of
reasoning to show why the probabilities
in classical statistical mechanics are
what they are this turns into an
explanation of the fact that he'd only
flows from hotter bodies to cooler
bodies and all kinds of stuff like that
okay all kinds of claims of what's gonna
happen out there in the world okay it
does work yeah it succeeds right right
it succeeds but but if this is the
reason why these if this is offered as
the explanation of why heat is flowing
from hotter bodies to cooler bodies it
seems to me that you have to say hold on
a second I must've dozed off there at
some point because something happened
that seems kind of funny
I went from I have no clue to of course
I should expect that heat is going to
flow from hotter bodies to cooler bodies
I know how to assign precise numerical
probability values to various different
possibilities
you should say anybody who hears this
should say did I win the lottery or
something I mean I mean how did I get
all of this for free
okay how am I so lucky and why is it
that this constitutes an element of an
explanation of physical stuff out there
in the world that doesn't give a [ __ ]
what I know or don't know acting in some
particular way okay so so you know I
that always struck me as profoundly
mysterious and of course if you examine
the argument a little further that I
just offered it's a bad argument that's
not the only thing I can do that
respects the symmetries of my epistemic
situation the other thing I can do which
respects those symmetries and which
seems like a much more honest account
and direct account of what my epistemic
situation in fact
this is to say when I'm asked to assign
probabilities to these two possibilities
is to say which part of I have no clue
do you not understand I have no clue
means I have no clue of course I'm not
going to assign probabilities to these
two possibilities my epic situation is I
have no clue period end of story
if you have forced to assign a
probability to be the gun to my head I
mean if somebody held it that usually is
another option no it's not if somebody
held a gun to my head it seems to me the
right thing to say to them would be
you're being extremely unfair what
you're doing because there is no
rational thing for me to say okay now as
you said and this is a really
interesting difference between this kind
of this kind of way of justifying
probabilities in something like
classical statistical mechanics and this
way of justifying probabilities in
something like Everett or in general
what people call self locating
probabilities in the case of classical
statistical mechanics the things I'm
attaching probabilities to are different
physical configurations of the world
okay as you correctly said just now
those numerical assignments of
probability turn out to be empirically
correct okay so all that requires
alteration in our attitude toward
statistical mechanics if you were to buy
my argument okay is if you were to buy
my you know I have no clue argument is
just that oh right
these probabilities weren't a priori the
the world isn't doing that because I
didn't because I had no clue these these
probabilities turn out to be empirically
correct as you said and if somebody says
what kind of status do you think they
have it seems to me the correct answer
is they have the status of statistical
empirical laws of how the world is
arranged okay and we believe them
precisely because of their empirical
success this is this a reflection of
your human brain yes I guess I yeah yeah
it is it is good when we get to so in so
the summary of the discussion of
classical statistical mechanics is you
made a mistake here but the mistake
didn't in any way [ __ ] your
scientific enterprise it's just there is
this probability distribution you were
right about what it's numerical values
were it's just that you thought you
could derive at a priori and that turns
out not to be true your reasons for
believing it are empirical and if
somebody says but gee it seems so
reasonable to me the the person who has
my sort of position will have a ready
explanation there look these are true
statistical laws and they're very
general ones there's every reason to
expect them to have been very deeply
hardwired into us since we were fish
okay by natural selection okay that
doesn't in any way put in doubt the
claim that they're ultimately empirical
generalizations although they may seem
to us extremely intuitive and exactly
what we would expect and so on okay you
don't think that that explanation is
available for everybody in so here's the
difference in the Eveready encase and
let's not talk right away about Everett
let's just talk about the more general
notion of self locating probabilities so
here's an old example due to david lewis
imagine that there are two brains in the
world at a certain moment in its history
imagine that at that moment these two
brains are in exactly the same state
okay
and moreover except they're located in
two different they're located in two
different places right they're in
exactly the same state that
is visa vie their associated mental
state right they may even have two
different bodies or something like that
but they're meant their current mental
state is exactly the same suppose
moreover that it's part of this mental
state that they share that they know
there are these two things in the world
then Lewis says each of them could
rightly wonder I wonder if I'm the one
on the right or on the left okay even
though there's nothing about the
physical state of the world that they
don't know okay and so there could be
another kind of uncertainty unlike the
one we were discussing before in the
context of statistical mechanics it's
not an uncertainty it's not anything
that you lack knowledge of about the
objective physical state of the world
okay
it's it's something that is compatible
it's a kind of uncertainty that's
compatible with complete knowledge of
the physical state of the world just
like you have in Everett in that in the
context we've been discussing but still
there's something you don't know about
where you are in there okay and suppose
that we were to start a indifference
type of argument here there are there
come up with a priori principles about
what kinds of probabilities we should
assign here the case is crucially
different than in the earlier
statistical mechanical case in the
earlier statistical mechanical case the
lucky thing was you philosophers you can
have all the arguments you like it
doesn't matter okay because we have
empirical access to what the correct
probabilities are but if two people are
having a debate okay what they're about
to split okay one of them says I believe
I'm going to end up on the right the
other says I believe I'm going to end up
on the left a third says or rather there
somebody some single person is
entertaining three theories
- one of which they got a 90% chance of
ending up on the right according to the
second of which they got a 90% chance of
ending up on the left and according to
the third of which they've got 50/50
chances in this case since the
probabilities do not attach to claims
about the physical configuration of the
world there isn't going to be an
empirical access to them okay we're
thinking of these choices is actually
arising from a quantum measurement
branching the way yeah yeah so suppose
we get with 100 percent probability but
really do come true somewhere in the way
correct both really do come true but now
we're assigning different probabilities
to our finding ourselves but in one
branch or the other here as opposed to
the classical statistical mechanical
case what we're assigning probabilities
to doesn't have the form of Akal
configuration of the world all the
different theories completely agree
about the physical configuration of the
world they're just disagreeing about
where I'm going to find myself in there
because they're not disagreeing about
the physical configuration of the world
it's obvious that you couldn't set up an
experiment for example that has the
following property if Theory one is true
the number one ends up being written on
a piece of paper at the end and if
Theory two is true the number two ends
up being written on a piece of paper
because what ends up getting written on
a piece of paper is part of the physical
configuration of the world that's going
to be the same under any of these
circumstances okay so all we're gonna
have to go on here is the a priori
argument okay and if somebody finds the
a priori argument unpersuasive then we
really are that really is going to
[ __ ] our ability to do physics here
in a way that it didn't in the classical
statistical mechanical case because
there's not this other non a priori
empirical access to what the right
probabilities are you can say suppose we
run such an experiment
repeatedly guy splits once but each one
splits again each one splits again okay
good
there'll be one guy who got all all all
the particles on the left there'll be
another guy who got all the particles on
the right there'll be a much larger
collection of people who found some of
the particles on the left and some of
the particles on the right good look at
the guy who got them all on the left
he says the the theory that it's 90% to
the left was very well confirmed by what
I saw all the other people suppose he
can talk to them unlike in Everett they
all start screaming at him what are you
talking about we confirmed completely
different things of course the guy who
found them all on the left they'll say I
am at ur of physical determinism that
you guys were all going to be there
saying this okay I'm asking about
confirmation or dis confirmation about
where I was going to end up okay
that's confirmed on the left the guy in
the right will say the same thing about
the other theory and all the guys in the
middle will say the same thing about the
50/50 theory okay there's not going to
be a definitive way to settle this
we might and I think from a conversation
you and I had yesterday that that this
might be the the reaction you would have
in mind you say yes I agree with all
that the kinds of probabilities how
shall I put it the sense in which one of
these probabilistic theories is
confirmed or disconfirmed by such
experiments is a purely indexical sense
an irreducibly indexical sense that is
it is not possible it doesn't make any
sense to ask did this sequence of
experiments confirm or disconfirm
the theory universally that's right you
say that it confirmed that or
disconfirmed it for i you know i think i
think the never reading has to say that
because there will be always some real
branch the wavefunction where everything
went screwy for all of history no no
that's true but I but if for example if
the decision theoretic argument had
worked which I don't think it does they
wouldn't have had to have resource to
this new and metaphysically puzzling
kind of purely indexical fact okay but I
think that there will always be people
who draw the wrong conclusions in an
ever Eddy multiverse sure that's right
that's okay if they are if if they're
you see we're gonna get into a
circularity here I think it's fine if
there are people who draw the wrong
conclusions as long as it's the case
that there's one reason or another not
to take them seriously okay now you
might want to say we don't have to take
them seriously because they're in there
implausible yeah they're unlikely to
avoid that okay that's clearly cheating
then then we're gonna get in [ __ ] right
and and other than that I mean I take on
board these purely indexical facts I
mean I don't it's at this point that
that it gets hard for me to see my way
clearly through so we're talking about
some new realm of facts purely indexical
facts and I guess I'm gonna want to know
elastic cases not obvious to our the
audience indexical meaning where you are
in the universe it's some fact of
location or let's put it this way that
this it philosophers call statements
indexical where the meaning of the
statement depends on the circumstances
under which it's made okay if I say if I
say I am wearing a black shirt that's
true if you say I am wearing a black
shirt that's false
okay now in most ordinary cases this
doesn't cause a problem because we can
translate the statements using indexical
x' into statements using non and
cicles we could say no no what's going
on here is that David is wearing a black
shirt and sean is not and we can get rid
of that okay in the cases we're talking
about the statements we're concerned
with are irreducibly indexical we can't
take the eyes out of it we can't take
the indexical terms out while still
meaning what we want to mean okay this
is only difference is which branch of
the wavefunction exactly exactly so so
if we really need to take on board into
our metaphysics facts like that in order
even to formulate our most basic
physical theories
that's a scary and puzzling situation
for me and let me distinguish scary from
puzzling scary
maybe scary is too strong a word
undesirable just because we have other
ways of solving the measurement problem
on the table that don't require us to
speculate about these new kinds of facts
so other things being equal which of
course you will deny that they are but
other things being equal that should
strongly preference the other ones the
second point is it's just puzzling I
need to so so you know so somebody with
sort of philosophical inclinations is
immediately gonna say whoa whoa we've
got this whole new set of facts here I
there's all kinds of things I want to
know about how these things work how
they're logically related to one another
what combinations of such facts
deductively imply other such facts and
so on and so forth I want to know a
semantics of this kind of talk I want to
know a logic of this kind of talk you
got to give me a few days here and I you
know I got to sit down and and think all
this through so so first statement so
and I don't know and and the the sense
in which I want to be non-dogmatic here
is I don't know how that thinking would
come out yeah maybe there's a consistent
way to talk about all that maybe there's
not if there's not then the view is
ruled out in a very decisive way if
there is then it becomes more of a
balance between various digital rata
that we might have scary but exciting
and exhilarating in my tradition you
maximize regret weary traveler cut off
here so I have not maximized regret this
was great thanks David for being on the
podcast thank you for having me it was
lots of fun
[Music]